분양 당시 줄서 청액했던 건물이 지금
절반도체 차지 않았습니다. 왜
하이엔드의 꿈은 첫참이 무너졌을까요?
네. 네, 안녕하세요. 빌사남입니다.
어, 최근에 그 하이엔드 오피스텔
관련된 기사들이 굉장히 많습니다.이
기사 같은 경우에는 롯데 건설에서
시공했는데 노년이라는 오피스텔 있는데
이거는 무려 84%가 비어 있다라고
합니다. 거의 다 비어 있어요. 근데
지금 이것뿐만 아니라 하이엔드
오피스텔도 보면 비어 있는 오피스들이
굉장히 많아요. 물론 이제 내부는
되게 너무 잘 돼 있어요.
고급스럽게. 네. 되게 잘 돼 있긴
한데 일단은 가격이 너무 비싼 거
같습니다. 네. 가격도 너무 비싸고
월 임대료도 굉장히 비싸요. 물론
이제 그때 코로나 때 딱 저금리 때
이제 뭐 금리 상황도 너무 좋았고
PF도 너무 잘 나왔고 그리고 그때는
포장만 잘하면은 되게 매각이 잘되던
그런 시장이었는데 코로나 때 그때
아무래도 상황이 좋다 보니까 땅을 사
가지고 이제 하이엔드 오피스텔 만든게
이제 지금 시기에 다 좀 준공하기
시작했거든요. 근데 아시다시피 지금
시기는 부동산 경기가 워낙 좋지 않고
금리가 물론 이제 내려가긴 했지만
아직까지 되게 높은 상태기 때문에
이런 하이엔드 오피스텔이 굉장히 좀
공실률이 많아졌습니다. 그때만
하더라도 거의 다 완판됐어요. 네.
완판될 정도로 많은 사람들이 뭐
세컨하우스뿐만 아니라 자산가들이 약간
아지트로 쓰려고 어 실제로 계약을 좀
많이 했었습니다. 근데 막상 지어
놓으니까 가격이 일단 비싸고 그리고
공급이 되게 많아졌어요. 그때 뭔가
열풍이었거든요. 그래서 지금 막 짓고
있는 오피스텔은 거의 다 공실이라고
보면 될 거 같습니다. 그래서 여기
앞에 저도 가서 봤는데 전는 일단은
좀 가장 눈에 띄었던 거는 물론 시설
이런 건 좋지만 거의 20층 되는
오피스텔인데 그 층마다 거의 뭐 한
뭐한 다섯 개 여섯 개 정도 세대가
있는데 엘리베이터가 두 대밖에
없습니다. 이건 되게 불편합니다.
그리고 주차가 기계식이에요. 네.
그래서 만약에 주차를 한다라고 했을
때 피크 때는 아마 차 찾으려면 거의
몇십분을 기다려야 될 정도로 되게
불편할 겁니다. 실제로 거주하면.
근데 아무래도 땅이 한정적이고 최대로
뽑은 면적이다 보니까 그렇게 기계식
주차라든지 뭔가 엘리베이터라든지 이런
거를 어쩔 수 없이 그렇게 만들어
놨는데 어 하이엔드 오피스텔이 좀 뭐
몰락했다 이런 기사들이 좀 많이
나왔고요. 그리고 이제 어 최근에
뉴스들은 뭐대 뭐 주택을 규제하자
수익형 부동산에 돈이 많이
흘러갔다라는 내용입니다. 지금 주택이
대출이 6억밖에 안 나오고 그러다
보니까 대출 제한이 없는 이런
오피스텔이나 이런 꼬마 빌딩 쪽에 어
많이 돈이 물렸다라는 기사인데 실제로
거래량이나 거래 금액이 늘기는
했습니다. 네. 근데이 딱 기사만
보면 빌딩 거래가 완전 많이 늘었나
이런 생각이 들 수 있는데 실제로
상세하게 들여다 보면은 이런 큰
빌딩들이 많이 거래가 된 거예요.
예를 들어서 뭐 테이란로 있는 건물들
SI 타워 같이 뭐 8,억짜리 이런
큰 빌딩들이 많이 거래가 됐고 우리가
일반적으로 투자하는 꼬마 빌딩 정도의
규모는 그렇게 많이 늘어나진
않았습니다. 진짜 공실이 없다라는 뭐
기사들이 많이 나가는데 그것도 보면은
큰 빌딩들 같은 경우에는 공실률이
되게 낮아요. 프라임급 빌딩 같은
경우에는 진짜 공실률이 너무
낮습니다. 들어갈 만한 건물이
없어요. 근데 우리가 반면에 우리가
일반적으로 투자하는 빌딩 같은
경우에는 오피스 공실률이 되게
높아요. 근데 여러분들이 뭔가 서울
오피스 공실이 그렇게 낮다라는 기사만
보고 어 그렇게 판단하시면 안 돼요.
그래서 세부적으로 들어가서 보면은
이제 조그만하게 뭐 연면적 뭐 3,평
이상 뭐 몇 층 이상 뭐 이렇게 해
가지고 통계를 낸 자료인데 그게 마치
뭔가 전체적으로 오피스 시장이 다
좋은 거 같이 이렇게 돼 있는데 어
그거는 좀 상세하게 보셔야 됩니다.
그래서 여러분들 항상이 기사 보실 때
어 이런 그래프뿐만 아니라 뭐 진짜
대형 빌딩들이 거래가 됐는지 내가
찾고 있는 빌딩들이 거래가 됐는지이
정도 사이즈의 건물이 거래가 됐는지를
그렇게 상세하게 보셔야지 어 이런 좀
오차를 줄일 수 있다라고 생각을
합니다. 그래서 뭐 거래량이 좀 많이
늘어났다라는 어 기사 봤었고 이런
금리 인하랑 뭐 이런 대출 주택 규제
때문에 하반기에도 더 회복될 거다라는
전망이 많은데 저도 여기에 대해서는
동의는 합니다.네 네. 어찌 됐든
금리도 많이 내려갔고 네. 대출 규제
때문에 아파트 투자자분들이 실제로
빌딩 시장에 많이 들어올 것으로
예상이 돼요. 어, 코로나 때 정도
수준이 되기는 어려울 거 같고
앞으로도 저는 좀 쉽지 않을 것
같습니다. 근데 어찌됐든 지금 빌딩
사기에는 좀 조건이나 이런 건 굉장히
좀 좋은 상태라고 보여집니다. 그래서
어 제가 뉴스 브리핑 코너를 좀
만들었는데 이렇게 좀 지금 빌딩과
관련된 이런 자산가들과 관련된 이런
기사들을 앞으로 좀 이렇게 출해
가지고 영상을 좀 계속 정기적으로
촬영할 예정이니까 여러분들 관심 있게
봐 주시면 감사하겠습니다. 오늘 영상
여기까지 하겠습니다. 감사합니다.
[음악]